la gráfica de f se muestra a
continuación sea gtx igual a la integral
de 0 a x df de tdt y bueno tal vez al
principio cuando vean esto van a decir
como esto es muy extraño tengo una
función que está definida por una
integral definida y además uno de sus
límites es x y deberían decir bien esto
realmente creo que está bien una función
puede estar definida de cualquier manera
y como veremos en realidad es bastante
fácil evaluarla entonces nos preguntan
cuánto vale g de menos 2 entonces lo que
vamos a hacer es tomar esta expresión
que tengo aquí esta integral definida y
donde sea que veamos una x vamos a
colocar a menos 2 entonces esto va a ser
igual a la integral definida de 0 a x y
voy a poner a x en un segundo con su
respectivo color de efe de tdt y bueno x
ahora es menos 2 así que como
encontramos cuanto vale esta expresión y
bueno inclusive antes de que vea
esta gráfica podrían decir que esta es
el área debajo de la gráfica
efe dt / m 2 y 0
y arriba del eje x es decir es esa
región pero tienen que ser cuidadosos
noten que nuestro límite superior es en
realidad un número menor que nuestro
límite inferior así que estaría muy bien
intercambiar estos límites y si lo
hacemos entonces podremos verlo como el
área de la región debajo de la función f
dt sobre el eje x y entre estos dos
límites de integración así que cuando
intercambias los límites esto va a ser
igual a menos ojo este signo menos nos
ayuda a intercambiar los límites menos
la integral definida desde menos 2 hasta
0 de ft
dt y ahora quiero que observes esta
integral que voy a poner de color
magenta sin el signo de menos ahora lo
podemos ver en esta gráfica
estoy coloreando de magenta el área que
estamos buscando es decir es el área
debajo de la curva
efe dt
entre menos dos y cero entonces entre
menos 12 0 ésta es la que nos interesa y
arriba del eje x y qué valor toma esta
área bueno hay un montón de formas
diferentes para poder encontrar esta
área podrían no ser lo que se me ocurra
es que podemos dividirlo en un cuadrado
y un triángulo y así obtener esta área
el área de este cuadrado de aquí es 4 es
2 por 2 y asegúrense de ver las unidades
a veces cada cuadrícula no forzosamente
representa una unidad cuadrada en este
caso si lo hacen pero siempre es
importante revisar las unidades entonces
estos 4 y luego acá arriba esto es la
mitad de 4 lo puedes ver así si todo
esto fuera 4
el triángulo es la mitad de 4 entonces
va a tener un área de 2 o lo podremos
ver como la base por la altura por un
medio lo que sería igual a 2 por 2 por
un medio y entonces me dan 2 así que
esta área de aquí es a 6 entonces esta
parte de aquí que atrape con color
magenta va a ser 6 pero no podemos
olvidarnos del signo negativo entonces
esto va a ser igual a menos 6
y ya podemos decir que es de -2 va a ser
igual a menos 6 y hemos terminado